lea wearing the bodyguard
hallo
you hear me get him
Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon. We just trying not to be so loud for once in
a while. Does your dad use those fancy made up scotch words like gobsheet and bampo? A
wee bit. He's much worse lying than me. Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon. I'm
trying to be a wee bit quieter. But that's because my dad's here. I'm trying to be so
quiet. I think he's still asleep. So, but I had the worst day ever yesterday. I'm so
sorry I couldn't tell you. I didn't want anyone tracking his flight. I didn't want
any weirdness. So my dad's here. I was violently car sick yesterday. So I feel awful. I've
had five hours sleep. I didn't have my nap. I don't even know if I've had five hours straight
to be honest. But we're gonna we're gonna figure out this game one way or another. So this
is Spyro, which may or may not be your childhood game. Because it's not mine. It's still my
game. My master. No, I've not played it before. So Crash Bandicoot got remastered and so did
Spyro. So I don't know if it's the same studio or if it was just rival studios that were
smart enough to re-release classic games. Like if they re-release cameo. So I'm jumping
right back on that. Thank you for streaming despite being a game, but also self care one.
Well, I have, I don't know what we're gonna do about ASMR streams because so my dad passed
out and he's got his own room in over him. And his snoring is so loud. I don't think I
can do ASMR for the next three weeks. I'm really unsure what's gonna happen. I beat the second
Spyro over at my best friend's house. I'm surprised you never played this. I don't know if Spyro
came out after, I mean before Crash Bandicoot. There we go. I have no idea. No dad snoring
ASMR. Oh, he like proper snores the house then. The bloody cats are scared of him. Gimli
and Vigo didn't come out. But yeah, I'm so sorry for the entire, we're gonna give Spyro
a shot. I assume it's Spyro the dragon I'm supposed to do, right? Yeah, seems right. That
was fine. 100% question mark. They need to get used to them. Yeah, they do not. Gimli
and Vigo. Oh my god, they have cutscenes.
Okay, rolling. Oh, it's been peaceful here in the five worlds, or is it six? For a dragon
to eat, you now have 12,000 treasure, or is it 14,000? What about this Ganasty Gannok
character? Now, I'm a Ganasty magic spell to turn gems into warriors for his cause. I'll
gentle confirmed. Wait. So yeah, I'm gonna give your childhood game a shot. See what I think,
because I share my childhood game all the time, so it's time for me to play a new game.
Wait, they have old music. Wait, why didn't... Oh, he talks.
Wait, why didn't he make me green?
Is this a remake of the original Spyro? It is.
So X is charged, B is flamed. Is it unlimited? I don't really see a bar. What's Y?
What's Y? X at look. Hold on, sorry. Wait, right trigger is attack as well.
What's this? Rescued nest. I didn't do anything. I walked forward, sir. Please,
please do not give me more accolades for things I didn't do.
Oh my god. Thank you, hit Vocaloid, Iniku Hatsune, for becoming a member.
What about NastyNork? I'm going after him. I'm going to find dragons first.
That's all I can tell you. Right, we're to find dragons.
I mean, I think it's as simple as that. I'm going to say no. Right, there's a green one over there.
Oh, I can fly with wings. Delvin. That Miku? Oh my god, she literally...
NastyNork out towards you. Keep your horns on, Spyro. You have much to learn.
So I'm a baby dragon. Do you know what the dragon fly following you is doing?
His name is Sparks and he's helping me protect you. Keep an eye on him and see what I mean.
Please... where is this?
Oh, I missed.
Wait, I can't touch water? Is it because I'm a dragon?
Okay, sorry, I'm just getting used to this. I've almost perished because I'm a dumber.
Oh, I'm locked to place. Do I want to go there? Does it matter where you go?
I do see portals going out and Joes don't read your health.
Oh, he looks so messed up.
Old video games and conditions to expect water to always be lethal.
Literally, I didn't realize I was hurting myself. That was a bit of an oversight from me.
Oh, I've got my cup of tea. Treasure found. Oh no, is this like 100% the game to progress?
Or is it just... you can go wherever you want. Oh, okay.
But yeah, how are you guys? Other than... oh my god, what?
Are you squid merit? I've just come for the worst, like one.
Mama dipping into my childhood on my 24th birthday.
Oh, birthday.
Best present ever. I hope you have a fun.
Oh my god, happy 24th birthday.
Snowberry smoothie. That's such a cute name. Thank you for the 20 as well.
Yeah, I'm trying to play your childhood games. Oh no, the controls are embedded.
I assume I go for the barrels, right? Oh gosh.
All right. No, okay, okay. I thought we were gonna like lose momentum or something,
but I'm gonna just follow the rail track.
But yeah, basically, I cannot travel at all. I don't know what I'm gonna do.
Because I'm memeing about this convention and stuff,
and I could hardly be in a flipping taxi.
Get right. Oh my god, I'm actually so smart with a heck. I love kids games.
I love games that are really obvious what you're supposed to do.
I don't know what the heck this is, but I did spot it.
Plus three. Time? Oh, I need it for something? Time's up. Would you like to retry?
Huh? I'm to do eight planes, eight chests, eight trains, and eight arches.
Is that not?
Have I just picked the hardest mission to start on? Actually, if actually.
I see a chest this time.
Oh, I'm on the floor. Oh, indeed.
Okay, I'm up to something else. I don't think I'm supposed to do that one first.
You have to get all of the things before the time runs out.
Right, we're not doing any flight missions. I said what I said.
Oh, but my health is regen. Doesn't even do anything for that.
Okay, what are you smelling?
What does he do?
Getting around him. That doesn't seem like a nice thing to do, but oh, they're scared of me.
Okay, we'll take it.
Getting things gives you time back though. Oh, okay.
Okay, let's try whatever this mission is. I'm so sorry. I really don't...
I don't... I don't play this game. Hopefully I do it justice.
And yeah, and I don't sound too sick. I had to take quills, which is anti-sickness medicine,
and it takes away all the saliva in your mouth, and it's still in effect right now.
I think it ages ago. And my mouth is all dry, and my voice is all cracked because I was talking to
my dad, but my freaking throat was so dry, so I completely messed up.
But I've got to see my dad at the airport.
Oh my god, the poor taxi driver. He had to stop for me twice.
That ram looks so menacing in the distance right now.
Yes, I'm drinking it. I'm gonna see if I can finish my tea.
My freaking thigh. Oh, that was quite the voice crack if you heard that.
And my freaking... I was like gagging and throwing up. I had to ask the poor taxi man to
go to the side of the road for me. I had to... I was like begging him to put the window down on that,
and I almost threw it outside the car, like down the side of the freaking thing.
I have really bad car sickness. It's literally my biggest weakness, you know.
You guys are like, oh, Strony. Oh my god, hi, little fly.
Strony, how do you stream every single day? That's not possible. Oh, you're so strong.
You're so brave. No, my biggest weakness is cars. I can't be in cars. I can't be in buses.
I have been on a boat and not had any issues.
They had to nerf me somewhere in its cars. You know how the world relies on transport
to get anywhere, and I just use my bike to go to the shops. Yeah, there's a reason why I'm not
interested. Although, I read things that said if you get motion sickness in cars, but if you're the
driver, you don't get the same motion sickness. I literally watch me go to a convention in a
America and be like, right, that's me heading off now. And it's like four weeks before. And
everyone's like, what the fuck? And it's because I have to get a fucking boat.
The mobility buff is strong. Literally, I can hardly even leave the damn house.
Oh, okay. You threw up four, oh, four times in the car.
Fuck you. I can ram you too. Hold on. Gen two ram girl confirmed.
Just head on collision. Oh, sorry, the camera's a bit funky.
Try to get used to it. There's a camera just to when I move. No, you have to constantly do the
right except one is speed up.
Right, you and you. What's this?
Dragon.
Rescued Gildas. Hello. Oh, you're a painter.
Go for it.
And try pressing the action button to drop down midflying.
Listen, Glading just bad flying. What's this? Can you like 100% this game? Oh, why did you spank me?
Well, this, if he's telling me about Glading, I assume there's another dragon somewhere here.
It's just a, I have about a 3D with girl for gen two. That is terrible. I really want to develop
a legion, like a Roman legionary. Okay. What are these? Hello. Do you have coins inside you?
Have to do them. Oh, wait, it's out of bounds. This is out of bounds, I think. Okay, sorry.
I'm being a dumb dumb. What are you?
Are you running away from me? Nice try. Wait, he's actually kind of fast.
Wait, he's got an egg on him. Can I birth more dragons?
I will single handedly rise the dragon population.
Okay, I can cut corners. Oh, we're getting closer. I actually caught a few more corners and he's done for it.
I've got a special egg. What did that do? Torches as the egg thieves. Did he steal from us?
That's a jam right here.
I can climb. I think I can climb. I don't know if I'm supposed to climb or not.
I could, I don't know if I could produce dragons. That's quite a tall order.
You order. I don't know if you guys are in TikTok but there's this Scottish TikTok
like Chinese takeaway and she's like, it's called like Rebecca Box or whatever and it's like,
let's pack this customer's order. But she goes like genuinely, goes like order with her voice
and it just reminds me of when I say wild guard. There'll be like one person that knows exactly
what I'm talking about and everyone else is like, what are you on about, strongy? I swear.
We don't need chess. Okay, wait, how many dragons are there per level?
Asked or? Do you like the intro?
After you freeze all the dragons, the book will fry. Maybe a dragon girl would be fun for them too.
Wouldn't that be adorable? Wouldn't she be just the cute little bunny?
Anyway, I did not listen to what that was meant to. I think she's healing me when she does that.
Generally, three or four, the men you should tell you. Oh, if I press start.
Okay, okay, so there's two more dragons. We're gonna go this way then because we're not
going this way. I think I spawned here. Excuse me. Thank you.
Okay, stop. I actually love how simple this game is. I actually am enjoying it very much.
I'm so sorry if I don't fit something very enthusiastic today. I'm one tired baby.
I was hanging about at the airport for ages. My dad said his luggage just wasn't coming,
but I did it. What? I can't break titanium. Oh, come on.
Pardon me. How strong are my horns if I can do that?
These games in my childhood, two and three are so much better though. Oh no, I picked the worst one.
As your dad doing, he never slept for like 48 hours. He did not see a bed, so he's had better days.
No way. No way. I perfectly fucking had the gamer sense to know where the heck this dragon is.
You are a dragon and you're very strong. It's good to start here, but to his best.
The others just add a lot more elements to them.
What? Does he sound like the perfect old weeb? Oh, sure.
Okay, thank you for releasing this though. Right, so exit level and we get to keep everything?
I assume we get to keep everything. It's not like one of those games.
Returning to artisan.
Yes. Okay, it did let me keep it.
Oh, sorry. Excuse me. Pardon me. Come through. I just need a portal. That's all.
Let's stay. Oh, I'm scared to do any flight stuff though. It's like a flight mission,
so as I'll come back later, mate, I'm no interested right now. I'm too rubbish at it.
Was there a portal over here? You missed the gem. It didn't save the gem.
You need to collect gems if you want to do 100%? I've got a life for doing that.
The dark hollow. Ooh, the haunted.
But I have no idea how long we're going to play for actually. He should be waking up soon,
if I'm being honest. I'm trying to be quiet. I don't want to wake because he was like,
oh, you're not going to be that loud when you play games, are you? And I'm like,
you're joking, right? I'll be screaming down the mic.
But yes, when she becomes up, I think I'll redirect into her. I have no idea how long
this game takes to finish. They're attacking me. No, you're not supposed to actually attack me.
Right, we need three dragons. There's three frogs. Oh, wait, the frogs are healing up my dragonfly?
Oh, the dragonfly's eating the boos. Oh, wait.
Oh, sorry, I love the combat because it's so easy.
How many hits can I take in a really quick few?
Okay, oh, there's a dragon here. Darius. Four hits and I'm out.
I pray that your dad's a deep sleeper. Well, I don't know if we can do ASMR streams and I'm like,
oh my god, three weeks? No ASMR stream seems bizarre because literally it's my main focus.
I have entered the battle zone. Oh, yes, hell come here. Okay, feed drags. Okay, drags is back to being
focused. If we do end up doing no ASMR streams for three weeks, I pinky promise I will make
no, don't return home. I don't even got the other dragons yet. I pinky promise I will do like,
I'll shut you not like, back to back ASMR stream type stuff.
Neat glide from up here. You light the campfire.
Oh, we flings, we're camping.
Ew, that's so cute. I prefer when you play games though. Oh, I think,
I know everyone's got their, oh my god, I'm actually so smart for figuring that out.
Oh, life. The only time I can get a life is in video games, swing school.
Oh, I don't think I've been done this way. Nope. We'll do fine. We'll cry, but we'll do fine.
Oh, okay, again, right. So the big guy is fire.
Sorry, I'm trying to get used to this. Whoa, what? Can I only get his buff?
Oh no. Oh, I'm getting scared. Stop, stop. I'm actually scared. That scared me. Please don't do
that again. Put him away, yeah, man. Honestly, just a moment. I'm not doing it.
All right, you do it. He's smart too. I forgot that part. Stop.
Why does he have such a generic like spiral? Whoa, there's a key.
Okay, Reefling, it's time to lock up and give me,
I'm just the key dude. Must unlock his secret door.
I'm looking at the map. I don't know where my last dragon is.
He's like, hardly patrolling. Yeah. Does he even care?
Okay, geez. That was like so hard to grab him.
Aspire was a generic 90s teenager. Oh yeah, right. I'm on it. Like that's what I'm getting from him.
Can't flea mill, can't ram big. Grilled his butt. That was my only option. Oh, it's never going up.
He must be up there, head over here.
Hominah, hominah, hominah, hominah.
Oh, it has a key.
Oh, this is like such a polite little game. Okay, we can fire that one.
Okay, sorry, but this game is actually so fair. I love it. I just think I'm just going to be a
professional child's game like reviewer and stuff. It's because I suck at games.
Whoa, the Spiral Vs.
Taken over the mic? Well.
I like how the dragons are actually tutorials as well. That's so nice. I like it.
Okay, so if I, I'm not to leave, I'm to use the portal, which is over here.
Aspire's speedruns are quite the experience. Oh, we're in speedrunning.
I'm just going to try and collect as many dragons as I can before I go offline.
I'm going to have to definitely change up some of my schedule though.
Uh, I like how cute the game is. I don't know how easy it is to 100% with the gems or whatever.
Actually, it wouldn't be impossible. All right, we'll have with them. Right, I'm not
doing the fine mission because it sucks, so there must be another mission. You know,
something about this castle up here? Ah, the platform's here.
You're perfectly qualified for video game journalism then, and ironically,
what's this? Hello.
Knock, knock. I'm Spyro. Please let me in. Is that like the end of it?
Hmm, we did the haunted mansion. We did that one. I don't know what this one is.
Most of the gems are just hanging out in the world.
Oh. Resued Thomas. Congrats if your name's Thomas. I'll try and talk to you later, Thomas.
Oh, man. Yeah, of course. Thanks for the advice.
Stop. You're so generic. I love them.
Turn square. Oh yeah, we're going to civilization.
Hmm. Yeah, I was really sick. I had to go to a bakery at the airport. I paid $5.50 for a tiny
little lemonade bottle, and I had to get a sick bag off of her. I was like, I'm so sorry to ask,
but do you sell plastic bags at all? And she was like, I'm so sorry, I don't. And I was like,
do you, is it okay if I can buy a little paper bag off of you because I needed something to
be sick in in case I was sick on the way back? And she was like, oh no, it's fine. You can just
have it for free, darling. I think she could see I was like sick as fuck whilst I'm waiting for my
freaking dad. The same voice actor as SpongeBob. That's fantastic. Welcome to Town Square. None of
the dragons are re... None of the dragons are being reused. Like, they're all designed new. This is
so good. Okay, right. I assume I rammed them from behind. Oh no, I can burn them as well.
Uh, jump. I can't imagine paying for a bag like that. Well, in Scotland, you have to pay for any
bags you take away. Want me to ram it and jump? Okay. And like, I don't want to get in trouble or
anything for doing, like, for not thinking. So I was just like, oh, can I pay for these? She was
like, nah, just take it for free. You already got scum assed on the lemonade. Like, when you risk
you all doing empire. You do. So in Scotland, it's set up, you have to pay for like those takeaway bags
from any shop or whatever. And it's supposed to go to charity, but obviously it started it,
there were gonna be five pence, but then it's obviously changed to whatever the fuck they
want to charge because they make a profit on that, you know. I assume if I get a hundred gems.
Oh, I just made him perish.
The odd thing is that this is how the OG game looks in my memory. I'm always like that with
video games. Like, when I played Brotherhood, I was like, oh my god, this game's aged a little bit.
Like, just go to the graphics and stuff. And I was like, wait, I don't remember like Brotherhood
being the most top notch thing I've ever seen in my life. You're using your gamer
instincts. I mean, it's winning.
The egg. Uh, that would be me. If I was a dragon, I'm like, oh, I'm winded me.
I think there is a guy back here, but I don't know how to get there. No, I don't want to jump
back down. Well, it's more than 10 years old now at the time. It was so good.
So red. Hold on. I'm really struggling with the camera angle from being honest. I don't know.
I don't know if it's janky for you guys, but I had to get up there.
I don't claim on the phone. What? I don't claim on the phone.
Huh. Hold on. Let's just have the camera's wear back in the day.
Can I jump up in the very far now? No. Hmm. My gamer senses. Oh, no. What?
The game wouldn't force you to restart a mission if you're not complete it. How many
have I got? Yeah, I'm missing a dragon.
You had the right idea of gliding.
I didn't see platform that I'm supposed to go on though.
When you hear an an an an an, it means there's an egg thief nearby.
Sorry. Glide from the top of the stairs to the egg thief.
This can't be. No. Oh, wait. Maybe it was. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute,
Riefling. So you actually are so right. Hold on.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I just need to give it a really hard turn.
I don't know how you're supposed to figure this stuff out on your own child's game,
by the way. Oh, we did it. Glade to the secret egg thief in the town square. Okay, I can do that.
Where is he? He can jump. I'm gonna make him jump. Did it make me jump down?
It did. I need to go all the way back.
Yeah, I definitely can't reach that. Okay.
As if I missed it. How embarrassing. Anyone remember the live-action commercials of the
creepy sheep protesting this game? Someone protested Spyro before.
Backseat successful. Yes, you're more than welcome to backseat me. I have absolutely
no issues with it. I am but a humble crybaby colfish.
I don't know what I'm doing and I'm more than happy to be told what to do.
And no, do not add like a good girl at the end of that.
Okay, we did it.
It's quick, so that's fine. You're the clunk, clunk, clunk.
Sorry.
The back door is back on the main.
This Skyrim commercials had the cheap protests and oh the sheep
protests in the game because you hurt the sheep to get your HP back.
I haven't developed the urge to click gems on site. I don't know. You guys said it's easy,
but I don't trust myself that it's actually easy. Yet.
I'm not looking forward to this flight mission, but I think it's the only one we've not done yet.
Wait, is the game seriously over after the flight mission? Can I be?
Can I be?
All right, I think it is the flight mission time.
No, it's not over. The hot air balloon takes you to a new world.
I hope you hurt my destiny.
Right, we'll give this place a shot again.
If we don't get anywhere, we'll go speak to the hot, I'm sorry,
we'll go speak to the hot balloon guy.
I'm sorry, little sprax.
There are five flight missions, one in the world. I've got another five worlds.
The only legitimate challenger in the first fire games are the flight missions.
The bosses aren't even responsible.
There are, right.
Oh, I did. Oh, okay. You didn't see that. You honestly didn't see that.
How about we just go to the next world?
Yeah, I agree. We should just go to the next world.
A freaking priced X thinking it was going to flamethrower.
I'm so sorry.
I was so freaking sorry. That was so bad.
I'm actually so embarrassed. I don't want to do that.
Do you hear me? Do you spank me with a heel?
No, you don't. I don't know what you do.
Right, no one saw that.
We're just going to move on to the next world
and because we've totally done all the missions in this one.
I missed our hot air balloon guy.
Hello. Wow, I see you.
I see you've been busy rescuing dragon Spyro.
Yes.
You may travel to the peacekeepers world if you like.
Are you ready to go?
Yeah, let's go.
The fairies just to check point.
Flight mission.
What flight mission literally starts the flight mission
instantly goes on the water?
Yeah, all right then.
Okay, talk about MLG Pro.
The flight missions are optional.
Oh, the developers.
I could spiral developer team.
Thank you for letting me skip the flight mission.
I didn't see a dragon.
Okay, let's see this new area.
What? Hello.
I hear an enemy.
Titan.
Those devs owe me.
Wow, what an interesting color scheme.
Wait, I guess because they're dragons,
they won their money.
Oh, here he is.
Here's cannon.
I'm just a wee dragon.
Why are you cannonballing me?
Why are you shooting me?
That's really, I'm just a wee dragon.
Right, dry canyon.
Don't say it, don't say it, don't say it.
Can't wait to see your reaction to a boss.
You will laugh.
You gotta do some yard work.
Oh, you can move in the little wooden thing.
You skip the boss level for the art level.
Is that what was behind the door?
How did I get through the door?
You didn't say it, but I thought it though.
Oh, funny.
I'm sorry.
And Kana needs you to eat that.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that to the other one.
That's this knock knock.
Okay.
Oh, can I just go?
I'm just going to send it by the pope.
I just checked the price for the triology too expensive.
I'd rather just spend money on one.
You know you're allowed to treat yourself right.
Thank you so much, bully legend.
Oh, I missed.
Sorry.
Can I go the opposite way that he goes?
Oh, well, I got him.
I was going to say, can I go the opposite way he goes?
So I can't interact him.
What do you do other than get in my way?
Oh, he's going to shoot him.
Rescued coin.
Thank you again for the super chat, bully legend.
It's 12 bucks on steam.
You can, but he'll turn.
He'll run the other way.
I cannot believe.
Oh, that was water.
Sorry.
I never even saw that.
I was too busy focused on the guy.
I got an achievement for charging a vulture.
Sorry, you can't ram big guys.
But I can try.
Come here, everyone.
How many dragons are on this level?
There are four dragons on the, oh,
there are two more dragons to collect on this level.
It says it's 40 bucks for me.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, I love the dialogue.
I was born to glide.
I love you, Spyro.
This game is so cute.
No, no, no, don't shoot.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, hold on.
Yay.
Oh, sorry.
I keep forgetting and then jumping.
Ah, oh, don't glade.
Glade where?
That wasn't rewarded for glading.
Oh.
My neck.
Oh, thank you for the read.
Kylie won.
I'm praying I'm sorry.
Thank you for the read.
I appreciate that.
Hi.
By the Pope, who was there?
I'm playing Spyro.
It's not my childhood game.
It's your childhood game.
And I don't know what I'm doing.
So I'm so sorry for the gameplay if it's frustrating.
But hi, readers.
I'm Strony Quotles from Motherfucking Vela, Gen 1.
Indulge.
Get it?
It's a big pun because you're supposed to indulge in us.
Who came up with this stuff?
Honestly, it was me.
I named it.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to any of the girls that don't like her name.
Oh, please.
That can give me a few hints.
Oh, I just got wallet.
Sorry.
I really need to heal, I think.
I think next practice is about to smack me.
Wait, he's not even with me?
I've lost my wee dragonfly.
Um...
Oh?
Hi.
Ivory.
Yeah.
I'm the baby.
Oh my god, that's so cute.
A wee puff of smoke when hitting our die.
Then you go back to the start where the rabbits are.
I didn't see any heals.
All right, I don't want...
Oh, I'm scared.
Sorry, I can't see where that guy is.
Behind me.
Is there any dragon that way?
No.
I don't see any bunnies either.
I'll let them think they're going to win, okay?
There's a one behind the castle, though.
Oh, there is.
He hid over that person.
He came up with that as a junior.
I didn't see a bun bun.
There's no sheebie in sight to eat.
I was going to throw that at him.
I...
Can I glide to...
Oh, I definitely can glide to here.
What are you?
Fireworks?
Oh my god, it's the 4th of July.
Again, sorry to everyone that lost a finger on the 4th of July.
We apologize greatly for your...
You lost.
I got yanked out of nowhere.
That was so rude.
So what happens?
Oh, I just respawned the real last left.
Oh, but respawned all the enemies.
They're limited enemies.
Oh, the vulture just not cared about me.
Sorry about that.
Okay, let's try that again.
Looks like I can glide over there.
It was like a souls-like ambush
when Anno literally when the guy's just waiting for you behind the door
and you're like, uh...
Oh, I literally forgot our 4th.
Oh, right.
You stop it.
You're upsetting me.
Give me that heal.
That's this way.
Oh, he doesn't.
I actually seem to kill him.
Oh, well.
Wait, I've already had the dragon here.
I just have to go backwards?
I can hear something all over.
Do not go back to that portal.
They must be...
Oh, there's my dragon here.
Oh, I see.
See him?
How'd I get to you?
Glide over there.
How'd I glide over there?
I'm investigating.
I'm thinking.
I'm using the environmental cues.
Oh.
Oh, bunny's here.
I'm gonna replay the games now.
They're so good.
Oh, god.
I just suck at them so badly.
If you press Y, we'll gain gliding.
You gain height.
That cuts my thing short.
Are you pranking me, Riefling?
Be honest.
Wait, I just hit a circle.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting a bit confuzzled in these games, right?
I'm supposed to glade to get to the next wagon.
Which I got 100% to.
Right.
There's water here.
If I jump, jump, jump.
I've already been to the left, right?
I already gladed to there.
That ain't water.
Oil?
Right.
Okay, hold on.
I guess I'll go back and take a right again.
How many am I missing?
Oh, just the one.
Which was like back there.
I'm getting spoiled rotten by the algorithm at the moment.
I'm not even kidding.
And Emmy fantastically got 10,000 subscribers.
I'm so freaking proud of her.
Wait, have I been here before?
I mean, I've been here before.
I mean, no, I have been here before.
I just don't remember.
I'll see if there's something over here.
I don't want to get booted off the map
because I'm ramming him,
but he's like so at the edge.
Right.
There was nothing even special here.
I love her.
She says dragon.
She says it like the wagon.
Dragon.
Oh, does it actually sound like I'm saying wagon?
Does it actually sound like I'm saying wagon to you instead of dragon?
If I start streaming, what do you recommend?
I mean, I like YouTube,
but I like YouTube because the rules aren't there.
Well, other than the recent ASMR fiasco,
their rules are normally pretty cut and dry
and it's pretty obvious what you can or can't get rid of.
I don't need jewels.
I need this wagon to the right.
That's over here.
Okay, it must be the Castello,
but how did I get up?
Whoa, I just make it look like this.
It has to be.
I don't see any.
Fuck.
Oh, no.
I have to go all the way around again
to try and make,
to try and be allowed to make that jump.
God, it sucks so bad.
You aren't far behind.
I'm proud of the V-Sucking.
No, I don't want to be first.
Okay, I need to just do a circle around here.
I'm too short.
Don't make fun of me.
No, I want the girls to be ahead of me.
I don't want to be like in the lead,
so I'm glad that Emmy took over.
I really hope Shibi can take over as well.
I think she can.
Hey, right.
What the heck?
Did I just send it?
Oh, shit.
Spyro, can you aim a bit better, please?
Thank you.
Right.
Jump.
Hold.
What?
I'm sure I can do it.
It's like so close.
And the VOD system is a man.
I also find that Twitch is only a good user experience.
Twitch mobile.
Are you squinting me right now?
Have you seen how to train your wagon?
What about the childhood shirt wagon tails?
Sorry, I think the way you say dragon is cute.
I'm saying dragon with an R.
Dragon.
It's not wagon.
Thank you for the five.
Veal or lover.
But oh, oh, for Spyro, buddy.
What was that?
You didn't even try to double jump.
I thought you could like double jump glades.
Ah, we're going to be here for a long time
if I can't even make this damn jump.
Then you aren't focusing.
You see the wagon.
Dragon.
My nuts on your face.
Double jump.
I'm trying.
I'm freaking missing it by a bore here.
Lord of Storms, thank you for the five gifted memberships.
Congrats to those who caught it with their face.
I think you do have to enable it if you're just bing chining.
If you're a lurker, I think the chat prompts you to enable it.
I'm so sorry this is taken.
I'm sure this is like a super easy jump
and it's just hard for me because I'm really low IQ.
All right, hold on.
Please, Spyro, please.
Does he actually get a boost if I press Y?
Because I will do it.
I will do it.
I need something to glide off to practice this Y boost.
Just learning curves exist for a reason.
What do you mean I can't be MLG pro in a child's game in two seconds flat?
Right, if I do, and then Y.
No, Y doesn't give me a freaking sec.
Path for the Storm.
I'm just trying to sleep.
There's no, don't contain the Scottish rage.
Honestly, I'm like, bro, I mean, we can always quit and go to the next mission.
All right, I'll give it one more shot.
This rest on my entire.
Okay.
And then right on the edge.
Come on.
I'm not going crazy or is that really hard for no reason?
All right, give me one more chance.
One more chance.
Just give me one more chance.
Oh, maybe you just can't do it that way.
Someone said just you're not supposed to jump from there.
There's nowhere else to be.
I can't get up on these wee things here.
Turn around and fly in whole.
Fly in whole.
That wooden door.
It's really hard, but you have to keep trying on the edge.
Stop at the stairs, turn around, then fly into a hole.
But hole.
But you're supposed to be the smart one.
I only have three brain cells and they're fighting for fourth place.
Try finger.
I do remember never beating this game because I was too frustrated and I did beat two and three.
Stone stairs of it back.
Okay.
Oh, you fucking twat.
Right, stone stairs and then fly into butthole.
Stone stairs and fly into butthole.
Is it from that ledge I'm supposed to do it?
Is it that?
Is it honestly that one?
Oh, I'm not losing it.
I'm actually losing it and I fucking get skin corn.
Oh my god, that's so evil from the dead team.
So is.
Oh, right.
Okay.
And then I just take a really short left.
Oh, for goodness sake.
Offer.
Bro, why did you guys let me do that for so long?
I'm embarrassing myself here.
That literally took a millisecond.
You let me struggle for how long?
Pass it.
Bend over.
You're all getting spanked.
You let me struggle for who?
We'll grab the key but we aren't really gonna.
Golf clap.
Good job.
Right, we got four dragons.
I don't know that was the solution but at your third try,
the lesson is that maybe that's not a solution yet.
I think I'll go with that as well.
But it looked like I was so close.
I mean, they probably did that for a reason.
Uh, right.
We're just looking for a portal.
Oh, they're scared of me.
Yeah, you should be actually.
Right, that's where I came in.
Oh, I never even unlocked you.
Sorry.
Hi, Magnus.
Yeah, please burn the tents.
Oh, we're pillaging now?
Oh dear.
Thanks again, Lord of Storms for the gifted memberships.
I appreciate it.
And then I get to see my moats.
I'm waiting for the next moat update as I just coughed there.
I should be coming in soon.
I think up next is Mercy the Moats.
Or is it Sheebie?
It's either Sheebie, Mercy, Azura, or Mercy, Sheebie, Azura, and then me last.
But that's because we can be patient for a moat.
I want the girls to have theirs first.
This isn't Elden Ring.
You probably can't just bash your head into a wall over and get into a works.
Well, that's why I normally spawn you guys in at that point.
Although I've been cheating from the start.
Like, I know I was supposed to use a, like, explore the DLC on my own,
but I just like playing games with you.
Like, I like when you hold my hand through stuff.
Like, I had so much fun playing the Jellybean game.
I was so excited.
I was like, listen...
Oh, sorry.
I like listen to some of the thing and you can hear the excitement in my voice
because my voice was, like, so light-pitched the entire stream
because I was just so happy playing.
So with you, I was like, oh, I don't really...
I was, like, up here, like, oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Instead of, like, my...
Usually, like, down here, generic talking.
Um...
Oh, I got snowball fight going on.
Okay, first dragon.
Oh!
There is a bat.
I think it just took my health.
I like how Micev indulges thanks to the same creatives
being commissioned first.
Mmm.
Well, the ACs are most actually a little bit different
than what we commissioned the first time.
But she was just super happy to get them.
And I was like, well, she's not complaining.
It means less work for me.
So I'll just accept them, which is terrible,
but, oh, I have to admit, I'm a bit tired
of doing, like, in the background work.
I think it's terrible.
Like, I love what I do, and I'm so lucky that I get to do it.
But, oh, I can't wait for, like, all the most order type things.
Thank you, CRC Error, for the membership.
It's really cute.
And...
Kendra?
The very VTuber?
Hello!
Thank you for redirecting into me.
We're just playing Spyro,
which is a childhood game of everyone,
but me, I've never played it before.
And I'm struggling a little bit,
and it's a bit cringe,
but it's still a kid's game,
so there's hope that I can complete it.
Um, hello!
I am Strony Culls from
Availers, Gen 1, and Dolls.
And that's pretty much it.
I'm wildly inappropriate,
so if you don't like that, please,
do not ever feel forced to watch me.
We're just playing Spy...
This is a dead end?
Oh, no.
Um, we're just collecting all the dragons.
We're not doing all the gems,
but this is Spyro 1 Remake.
Um...
We're just getting all our new dragons
and doing it right now.
What?
Thank you for releasing me!
Hello!
Okay, no more tutorial information.
That's interesting.
But yeah, we unlocked the little dragons
by touching the green statue.
Huge.
You've got the camera angle on that.
I'm struggling a wee bit,
but that angle stopped me.
No, it didn't.
Am I doing it justice?
I'm glad.
I feel like I'm so low energy today,
but I was very ill yesterday.
Oh my god.
That taxi driver was trying to take me out.
I swear he's like,
now I'm gonna fuck you up.
Thank you so much for the tip, Anonymous.
I'm glad you're enjoying it.
I feel a bit, um...
Insecure's a bit of a dramatic word,
like fucking relax.
But like, I feel a bit like,
oh no, I'm not really doing that well.
Um...
This game is perfect for a chill stream.
You're doing great.
I'm loving the dance.
Oh, thank you.
You're in a little ego boost, right?
I don't know where they're at.
Thank you.
Oh, how much they went right past the...
Is it there?
Or is it just saying that there's a shining gem there?
Okay, I think we're gonna have to backtrack
to try and find this other dragon.
And yes, I'm seeing dragon on purpose like that now,
because you guys are a billion, though.
Oh, it's okay.
You're probably doing better than me.
Uh...
The music's cute,
but not cute enough for Gen 2's background music
to be themed off of all.
I'm gonna see if I can be cheeky and get,
maybe,
Minish Cap.
I do like Minish Cap.
I really do.
Right, that's a ledge to jump over
if I've ever seen one.
Can I climb up somewhere?
I can.
Okay, I think it must be this ledge then.
Yeah, come on.
Nope, it's not.
All right, we're downflyed too.
Come on, give it to me straight.
Ah, I don't have the key for that.
Crash Bandicoot, twin sanity background music.
Yeah, I remember you beating the final boss like a real pro.
What?
Conk, conk, conk.
I'm searching, I'm looking.
What?
I don't...
Go away, please.
Is he gonna get me?
No.
I was like,
is the height difference about to enroll me?
Wait, I'm all the way back at the start.
Huh?
Where's this flipping dragon?
I never noticed that.
Is it like hiding?
Last dragon is hella hard to find.
Clearly, I've freaking gone past the dum-dum.
Is he like under a hidden thing?
Like, you gotta do a U-turn to get to it and fly down.
Mr. Bat, please.
Okay, he's gonna heal up Spark.
Is he here?
Oh, this is a bedding.
You have a mini map on the lower left screen.
Oh, I forgot about that.
Oh, you mean that big thing that really helps out
to tell you where like hidden locations and stuff is?
Okay, it looks like...
I...
Whoa, don't do that.
That was a very nice...
Okay, it looks...
This is just a platform for the sake of being a platform.
Oh, my sister go down there to get the denki.
So then what was the bed on that?
Something over here?
Wait, where did we dot something on?
Hmm, okay.
So there's like a weird U-turn in here?
Wow, that's so tall.
And I'm so tiny.
What's the lives up there as well?
Hold on, right, must be something back here.
Yeah, but qua, you're welcome.
To say you are welcome in French, you say?
Oh, this one's lured and the other one's.
Oh, my God, I'm so smart.
Are you squinting?
I'm so smart.
E-e-e-e-ego.
I just hear...
Do you want me to say it with a harsh Scottish accent then?
Dragon, is that what you want me to refer to all of them as dragon?
Oh look at my dragonfly of a health bar.
Thank you for the tip, Anna, on em' bullying me.
Brian, yeah, Brian, literally given 0s.
Okay, can I just like scoop past the section?
Oh, he's gonna end up hitting me.
The rule that are.
Ok, we have just committed a not very nice thing.
Oh, he's posing on me.
He's starting on me.
Defeat all three Scary Ginnorks.
I'm gonna off the Ginnork!
I'm gonna off the Ginnel!
I'm a Ginnooooor!
Yeah, we did it, okay, sorry about that delay old chap
Ragnar the ring another 10,000 gamers
I thought this was on game pass, but it was like pay money to buy it and I'm like well it's way cheaper on steams
Brian
Five foot three is not tiny for a woman, but your size makes me want to give you headpats
I
Thank you feel their lover. Well as their size is complete for an office that mean
I just want
Wait
Yeah, okay, we're well the dragons we hit home
Actually, I need to order artwork with the girls to be honest. I want to show off their hidden lore a bit more
Just like Azura can be as tall as a skyscraper
So, you know need to need that giant ass artwork coming through don't mind me
Shamelessly commissioned in that right. I'm supposed to burn
Right we did cliff town
That's either this one dr. Shim
I was curious about the Lord like her mercy became an egg student. I mean she pretty much finished up being a tailor so
Gras tiny at 47. Oh
No boss live
Don't say that is this a boss level
Oh
First thing I do in the levels hurt myself
Hold on I've got this only ones with people's names are boss level
Wait, you weren't I
I freaking all locked on to me, but it didn't last time. Don't be cheeky
So they just perish themselves, I mean, I'll take it I'm not gonna complain about it. I was oh
You can't do that on a big
Geez Louise
Oh
Scary
Secret path
Oh, it's just Jim's
Okay first a wagon on love
Terondo
Dr. Shemp thinks he's so cool. You don't know what it's been like listening to him over and over
But I tell you one thing you should watch his back
Every single interest in everyone thought Amy was a visual. I mean she can I believe that
This is a boss fight
Is that a boss mate? Oh, no, it keeps going. Okay. Okay. How many dragons are there? Oh, I've already done it
Okay, okay, let him get up. Let him get up. Oh he's raging. Whoa
I'm scared. I'm actually scared. What does it mean?
Uh-huh
So he's what spin
Okay
They're just fire
Okay, okay, I got it. I got it. It was time and it was just time and I can just spam it down
I didn't have to think of anything. Sorry
Okay, one more
What do you do this time?
Whoa
Are you just get Jules for the enemy side? Okay, okay, that makes sense
Bunk bunk bunk up first that's why I'm returning home
Stony that booty rivals your own gal only one of us can have the superior be in this house
That's what he gets for kidnapping acu-acu
This is a dead end
Do not touch whatever the purple stuff is. I don't know what it is. I don't want to know
Ah, okay cliff time we did
No, it's candy
Wow
Got the cameras a bit unfree. That's where I got him. I get motion sick playing this game
I did not get motion sick playing games, but that's where I came from
Oh, it's a life. Just beat you
Purple stuff is oil supposed to emulate Arabia. Oh, what? Which randomly pick
Oh
We're in the hall balloon guy here. I
Got go complete some of your assignments. Good luck with them. You should submit them to me so I can do them for you
the content
Only when I feel better that way am I going crazy?
I don't go past the balloon guy and he was gonna take me somewhere near
Go
Bun bun you heal up my little
Don't the balloon guy here, and he was gonna take me away
Hmm what a weird stone it has a target right on there and there's a cannon nearby
I
Can in your bag stall
No, I can act can't push these I don't think so
I can't I'm just gonna burn all the cannons
Hold on cannon cannon cannon. How are you supposed to figure any of this out?
Target I see the target I push it over
No, I can't offer goodness sake
Okay
Okay, okay, okay, not bad. Thank you for the hand. We got there in the end
It really gave me time to react to that
Good job job story is so clever. Yeah thought about all myself. Thank you
Keep up the good work, and I know you'll fulfill your oh
Hey strongy think you could teach us some Scottish Gaelic
I have a goal of learning new languages
I am so sorry, but I come from the mainland of Scotland, and I was not taught gaelic at all
aim
So I'm sorry to disappoint gaelic lover, but actually I can't teach it because I was never taught it myself
The only words I know are polis
aim
Oh
Police is polis and Scotland is Alba. Those are the only words. I know okay. How'd I get over here?
I still keep the dragon, right? Okay, if I keep the dragon. Oh, no, don't
What I need the balloon I
Can't believe I did that honestly
Only I would manage that. Okay, we're doing it. No, we're not we're not doing the night flight. We ain't doing any flights
Oh, sorry
That's where the whole other is the hot air balloon guy
Okay, take this I can't believe how fast you found so much stolen
Yeah, magic crafters I'm surprised you don't know any ranchy words in
Gaelic or Gaelic lover and
No one spoke it I come from the mainland of Scotland and now if you come from the islands up north or way up north
You're most likely to be taught it. So you're just talking an accent
Like a regional accent I and
Slang but like Scott slang but not Gaelic not Scott's Gaelic and I was never taught that they
So folk are actually wanting to be taught it so it doesn't
Juice I can't even see I'm around these damn corners. Oh, I can't jump
I'll
You
It's pronounced Alba and Gaelic Alba spell ELB
Oh, I love us. I
Love oh my god. No shit. There's that's one stop. Is it bad here?
Rescue the egg
I
Got walled
Wow, wow, wow, wow
Oh, it's with Shadow Wizard money games we love casting spells at the Alpine Ridge
You need to chase him in the other direction
And you teach Sunday in Scots so that we can flirt with the nice lassie on vacation
There's really not any nice Scottish slang that I can think of
and
If she's pregnant you see oh, she's up the Duff which is just
It's not that pleasant of a terminology
I guess technically if you want to ask a Scottish chick, do you want to be pregnant by me?
You'd be like odd you want to be up the Duff?
Or like I'll get you up the Duff. Oh, yeah up the Duff. I'm not even kidding
The fire back
Sorry, hold on. Okay. Well, if he's not gonna get me then he's not gonna get me
He can raid him
Isn't the Duff also fine for the but and Scots it just means pregnant like oh, she's up the Duff
But normally it's like a disapproving
taper
Is that them going out?
Plop plop plop get up the Duff basically if I did like a Scottish
Or do I'd be like get me up the Duff get me up the Duff
It just doesn't say it's not very pleasant terminology though
No
Get off the Duff get off the Duff get off the Duff get off the Duff
Thank you Raven
It's get up up up up to get off the Duff isn't a thing has to be up
Oh
Get it in the river
Mustn't be
Mustn't be a dead-on kind of you
You still make dragonfly
Huh
I
Like I said, huh?
Dragon crazy
Yeah, I didn't know what the game wanted me for there
Maybe someone doesn't want to get go. Oh my bad. I was thinking about the Chuff not Duff
Huh
Come on
That's such a distance though
No buzz
Oh
Can't yell
No, it doesn't need to give me more money as I was saying plop plop plop plop
Get up the Duff get up the Duff this get up the Duff
Thank you again Raven and it's it and ask me to get out the
There will be no birthing of the lot the only thing on birth in his gen 2 maybe gen 3
And then that's that's all the birthing. Oh, this is any more. I'm supposed to go
I'm not supposed to over there. I'm stuck over here now. Can he be?
A Spyro up the Duff. Spyro is not pregnant. He just has a little belly
Oh
This Leo is really confusing me. I'm confuzzled
Looks like I'm supposed to do something to open that platform type thing, but I've not done it so I keep perishing
I'm like on my own over here
Is there like a secret? Does this game have secret walls?
You should pass the lead
There also may be a way to catch the egg guy that escaped earlier as a person that has 100% at this game
multiple times both in childhood and after the remake watching this has given me a small panic attack
Why am I doing everything the wrong way?
The Geomancers are supposed to open it, but I don't recall where he is
So I've basically progressed on the side of the map. I'm not supposed to I
Like when Scots type funny and complain about things on to our baby coughing on our bus right as I needed to
Cough so I nearly exploded hold on in because I didn't want to look like someone who copies babies
Oh my god, my favorite one is I want to wrap myself up in tin foil and blow myself up to fuck
Okay, yeah, something's supposed to open this
Is it that twat back there? There might be hold on let me perish need reset
Honestly, if you type it in it's like want to wrap myself up in tin foil and blow myself up to fucking the microwave
It's the funniest thing. I'm fucking red. I love it so much
That's why I sometimes go like, oh, I want to blow myself up, but it's because of that tin foil tweet
Is it that? Is that why that ledge didn't open?
How confusing I might have to do a different mission
I'm not sure what the game wants of me. Yeah, all those guys have just spawned back in as well
I'm not supposed to get every single one and that's the the deal
So what I take a left destroy them all left side, and then it should open up wherever I'm missing
Get one oh he's too big
That was a bit cheap
Okay, no
And then what defeat this guy that's everything in the area defeated
I'm being trolled of this platform doesn't come down right I'm being trolled
I may have to quit this one. I don't know what I'm supposed to do
The game is tied to frames per second
I always interest and see how others play this game. You need to collect all the wee orbs
I need to be 30 frames per second
Is that real
Oh my god, it's so bitty. What oh my god, it's so bitty though
Oh
My god, oh
This looks awful though
And I put it back on
My ring cloud, thank you for the redirect
We're currently
playing
Spiral which is a childhood game of not me, but of you guys
and
I'm currently getting wrecked by Framerate. Oh, I can't a
For goodness sake. No, don't look close your eyes. Don't look at this embarrassment
site
Side chick kisses for you. I'm strongy calls from be a lure
I actually had the opportunity to play with rain cloud on and a moongers club
And
Might recognize the Scottish voice if not, it's perfect to find I'm strongy calls from be a lures gen one
And today indulges in journey. I'm so rubbish at this stuff
and and and and and and and then
And being close awesome, thank you. I thought you were Mexican motherfucker
Oh
Oh, it's me. Oh, where is the loo the wagons?
Don't it's the ugly
Hope stream is fine. Yes. Hope you had a fun stream too
Okay, I'm a health out. Oh, I'm in trouble. I don't know where the other guy is but
Can you eat the butterfly that came from that sheet or did there no have bar?
Oh, there's a butterfly. Go eat it. Look. I see it. It's like jumping up and down. It's fluttering get it
Fuck it up. Fuck it up. Tear it up. Oh, no, you're fine. You're so dramatic
Ugui is a turtle no dragon. Go on the S. The Lou dragon
This just for gems down here like it makes the Constraini stream
I don't speak any of the lingo though. I'd be doing a prey
You got absolutely wrecked. I mean, yeah, you just ever take that. Oh speaking of being right
Boy Strony
Sure, show the Oxford to the new
What are you even saying? We didn't see a moment
Thank you. Thank you, do you fling you understand?
Latina for Gentoo. I'm very curious to see how
Wait, is that all the dragons? No, I've missed one dress
Don't put me back out there
Where it must be on this side
Oh
See something. Oh, wait. No, I came from there
Fear the chancla should I get well get a milflatina and her gimmick is she can throw a chancla that would be our custom toggle
Right, there's definitely something over here. Oh shit. Was that supposed to do what I think I was supposed to do and
Fly from all the way up there over there. I think so. Oh, there's a ledge
It's a ledge now. Don't be fooled by the layout of this game. There's a lot of ledges
That kind of just pop it nowhere. Okay, let's try that again
Okay, easy peasy. Let me squeeze it. That was exactly what I was supposed to do. I was like a guy
Chancles are heat seeking
Oh my god, it's fire. You're actually so brave. I'm not wait, what do you mean?
Come on hitbox
You say I have to chase them around
I
If he's already taking off I'm not even near you mate
I'm running I'm running. I'm cutting corners. I'm cutting
Wow, I think I'm getting closer
I think I just got a ton far away because of that jump
Should I jump off this ledge instead? Oh
Maybe no, I don't know. I feel like he's getting further away from me and I'm didn't even well, maybe
No, he's like gaining a speed buff
Holy moly
Right, we did it quit the current game
You mean level
You mean quit the current level
Don't forget to like the stream reefless. Oh, I'm so sorry. I'm so bad at saying that
Oh, yeah, please consider liking and subscribing if you'd like what you see exit level. Yeah
Exit home
Yeah, I get to keep the dragons
Sure, just know you are gaining on them and bring the bill
And if you like ASMR, check out my gen maze. They're all releasing ASMR
Okay, I've done that one
As another one of you guys
Ah
He's like
Oops
Smash that like and subscribe and remember
Does it do that thing? I don't know if you remember
YouTube released an update so if the streamer or the in the video they say like hit that like button the like button
Lights up on your phone. I don't know if that's a solid thing or not
When you say smash that but smash that like button the button actually goes up because of speech recognition
Oh, thank you veiler lover, I've got a few tactics up my naughty sleeve, but that's in three weeks
And thank you again for the tip
Isn't that the subscribe button? Hi strongy chat. I saw that one time. I haven't seen it since though. Maybe we check out
Let's go the girls to tank at ease it's my goal this month, but I don't know if I can do it
Pupsy pupsy
Oh, no, I'm sorry if you have arachnophobia. No, there's no Jen girl
That is
insect
insect like
I'm so sorry, please look away if you have arachnophobia
Thank you, those are rookie numbers 10k those are lucky numbers to 100k I
Really hope I can get
Playbottoms for the girls. I
Really hope thank you. Really legend. We just need to sweat a bit and get that can tent push
I'll crash them all super charge makes you in
from pallet tones
Mom, what are you doing with mr. Mine?
Why does it? Why is mr. Mine dressed like that mom?
It's kind of freaking me out if I'm honest
Spiral voice actor chicken I need fire
Never play with fire in doors. Oh, no the pokemon trauma. I was freaking lost with me
Yay, I like the firework mr. Mime not professor
Mom
Professor oak. Oh, what are you two doing together?
What's going on here? Did you really send me away to become the pokemon master?
Just so you can fuck my mom
What the fuck?
oak
Mr. Mime sleep professor oak. Oh kiss
Are you serious right now mom? I didn't know you were such a slag
No, Americans don't sleep like
Gary and ash boy love mango. I am a I know that you're all can you don't have to hate it right? Where'd I go?
Is this another chain I'm gonna end up motion play you know, I cannot chase is it if this is just a day and then I won't bother
We still need three two more dragon
I guess the drills might be the secret
Not flag such a good impression. He wouldn't do it. What do you mean to my mom? Why are you guys rating my mom?
Don't you feel and bear speaking of being about whoa
Hello
Wait what
What was that supposed to happen
Where are you going? Are you just hating in the cavern for me?
But I don't think grand play should do a super charger around
Yeah, they can't chew oh my god, that's okay
Okay, that was cool I like that
This levels from running
I'm gonna
Wait, that's where I came from and that's a dead end that reason I have to go this way
Says there's something this way if I can get into the cast in
What kind of do can I not jump up on this ledge how'd I get to it? Let's get to it
Super charge kills the spider
Hi, hello, they're just hovering ready to pick me up
I feel sick
Motion sicknesses no joke kids take it seriously. Yeah, I'm gonna go back
That spider chasing
Oh you too fast
I
You see oh, and I just lost the house
I'll survive
Oh
Okay
Then you go get kissed by her again, thank you
I love in here
This is a respond I think
I
Fight in each other
You stop that
Okay, we've got a second
I've heard that and he has the means can help
Oh, I'm just wrong
Burn them all
He had a subway and you tell me doesn't feel good
Right what do you guys do you do a big old cross jump
praying
Yeah, I'm so sorry. I was like literally throwing up burping everything yesterday
Nothing came up. Thankfully, but I did have like the gags and I'm afraid I have not fully recovered from my tragic I
Wasn't supposed to do that or did I just miss by a millisecond?
One of the levels in this world has a song that eventually used as credit themes in the Amanda show this
Okay, I just missed I
I
Didn't commit and then because I didn't commit I died
I just thought I should tell you that no, please always hundred percent commit
Because I just freaking perished over nothing
So I'm done
And got scared, okay
Commit
I'm going to commit suicide wait, is this got the wagon on it? No
I'm sorry, it seems a lot harder than I first thought wait, so the dragon isn't there. Oh
My god, look at my terrible percentages on like everything
Is it this is it?
Where's the dead end?
Other than drills, I guess
And part in the earth bender
Yeah, the world basis says hope you mastered gliding
What a great audience
I don't know what to think eps drone it is because I feel so sick
I'm gonna have to change up what I thought my schedule was
and
Don't know what to change it to but you'd be nice to myself. I'm probably just gonna end up
chilling
Oh, I feel sick. I'm so sorry. It's just come on again that
Sorry, I keep doing that. That's the only thing I don't like about
Well, not that someone with like motion sickness, but
I'm sorry. I'm completely losing. I'm losing my flow. Okay. I'm losing my flow
Astronauts, you need a break. Yeah, I think this is actually going for my motion sickness
Which is I just saw that in the corner of my
Is she be coming up?
Feel ill
Who knew my biggest weakness would be fucking automobile and auto bang, but I'm gonna drink some more
22 minutes. Okay. Well, we do some marshmallows and memem. I
Don't think she's on today red question mark
How about I go to oh my god
I'm sorry. I'm just covering up the game screen right now. I cannot look at that anymore
That's it's a really really really annoying thing about and
What all my membership streams from yesterday all got limited ads
What did I even say anything that was that bad?
All four of my streams yesterday got limited ads
Do you want to come over and have a bite? I made cottage pie for the first time. Oh, that's amazing
You made British food. Is it all brown just like all the British food in the world?
Amy's actually live for sonic heroes unbelievable
Okay, let me just make sure that she be definitely isn't coming up and if she's not I'm so sorry. I'll check out
I'll check out
What will I check out?
She's doing smash or pass tomorrow with Toma. Yeah, she's not on
Hades break. Okay. Okay. I see it
What are you gonna do after stream probably go back to sleep I feel I still feel real
And it was it wasn't even the most intense car ride, but
I've only had five hours sleep. No nap and
Yeah
I'm a poor being. What can I say? No way Amy just went offline. Did you?
Say that coming
Amy at you may plus. Yeah. Oh wait. I'm saying it wrong. It's I
Did she literally just go flying am I going crazy?
I
Streamed a day ago stream 14 hours ago. Oh, she's coming on. I'll live in
Miss Mars playing Pokemon run a redirect into miss model think oh
Hugs and forehead kisses. Hi. I'm so sorry, but bye. I'm about to go
Don't feel very well. I'll open up marshmallow. Just to see if I can
questions and that
Actually, there's been a bit delay on the patreon audios. The girls should have their first one out, but
We'll get to it. Hi, scrawny. I love you. Don't feel better than I hopefully will feel better by tomorrow
I think I'll be okay
Thank you little refund
Yeah, better. Have a good sleep. Yes, definitely
If you want a short chill game for next week, maybe look at what remains of Edith Finch
Curious, I don't think I've heard that or seen gameplay of that game
Stony, thank you for making my tentacles so happy. Oh, yeah
Be a little accomplished great things. I'm not
Glad we could break your tentacle
Pat pat pat get Wilson. Thank you
First and foremost, it's a pleasure to finally meet our father-in-law. Let me introduce
Ourselves. We are the reeflings. Let me tell you that your daughter is the most amazing. Alright, I'll give it to my dad
Sorry, I won't read out if it's not for me. It's for my dad
Squids can't extend their tentacles to 20 to 40 ms, which is about 10 times faster than they blink
They are really impressive since they don't use any
Spring like mechanism. They only use their powerful muscles for this which can rear be rearranged in a crisscross pattern
I don't know that imagine a tiny reefling growing a 30-foot tentacle and striking out with it at lightning speeds to defend
Mummy in danger. That was so wholesome. You could have gone somewhere else with that
so
Um
Normally she be streams and she be doesn't have a public stream today. No, it's okay. Don't worry. Is she doing a member stream today?
you
I'm so sorry. I think I'm gonna have to call it there. I really don't feel well
I promise I'd stream longer if I could but I
Think I'm ready to throw up and I think I'm doing a mercy modest in the duck again
My stomach does not feel right. I'm so sorry. I'm gonna redirect into this lovely girl
I'll say hi for like a millisecond, but I need to go light and I'm so sorry reeflings. I apologize
But we did we give spiral a little bash. Thank you so much for watching me stumble through this game
It's very cute. I like it. I'll see you tomorrow. I don't know what the plan the action is tomorrow
I think the new schedule starts up, but I need to change that way
But thank you so so much and I'll see you goofy go bers tomorrow. Say hi to a
For me, okay. Bye. I'm so sorry